vielen dank auch von mir für die
einladung zu diesem sehr interessanten
programm und projekt ich finde das sehr
unterstützenswert eine ganz tolle idee
die genau zur richtigen zeit kommt wo
jetzt die krise wieder fahrt aufnehmen
was möchte ich heute machen ich bin also
kein experte was die bonner krise angeht
jetzt gehen quantitativer hinsicht oder
biologische chemische hinsicht sein was
nicht machen möchte ist die frage
stellen wie man die korona krise
philosophisch zu bewerten hat was heißt
es ich möchte jetzt nicht so sehr eine
quantitative interpretation der
statistische reputation der krise geben
da kenne ich mich viel zu wenig aus
sondern ist eine qualitative
interpretation geben und ich möchte auch
eine normativ interpretation geben also
ein bisschen was von tieren was durchaus
kontrovers diskutiert werden kann
also wir sollten wir aus philosophischer
sicht wie können wir mit der krise
umgehen und ich bin der auffassung dass
die krise uns die grenzen der
alltäglichen interaktion wie nur wenige
ereignisse der vergangenheit vor augen
geführt hat also zunächst einmal
schuldig oder krise uns brille freiheit
einzuschränken und nur negative aspekte
zu besitzen also handlungsfreiheit wird
drastisch eingeschränkt das
sammlungsverbot undsoweiter sofort das
weiß jeder von uns und jetzt kann man
sich fragen können wir der korona krise
nicht irgendwie positive aspekte
abgewinnen
müssen wir uns geschlagen sind wir
hilflos und ich bin der meinung dass wir
nicht nur hilflos der krise ausgesetzt
sind so dass wir neben medizinischen
fortschritt wir haben jetzt zeit diesen
neuen impfstoff der jetzt zu 90 prozent
offenbar die leute mobilisieren kann
entwickelt das ist eine möglichkeit ich
versuche jetzt noch eine andere
möglichkeit aufzuzeigen wie wir der
krise was abgewinnen können das betrifft
jetzt nicht nur die krise das betrifft
alle krisen aber eben jetzt speziell
diese krise ich glaube es gibt neue
dimensionen die wir jetzt erkannt haben
und diese dimension die zu der uns die
krise geführt hat die wir jetzt immer
mehr entdecken das ist die dimension
er wird schwer in realität auch dass das
wir gerade hier machen über suchen
kommunizieren und so kommunizieren das
ist wirklich eine realität der
kommunikation ist wir machen hier keine
spieler reisen dass wir machen das hat
wirklich bedeutung
das ist für mich eine form der
virtuellen realität und die scheint mir
eben durch die krise besonders deutlich
geworden zu sein weil sie cohen zitiert
mit der digitalen entwicklung und ich
möchte jetzt diese virtuelle realität
die durch die krise ganz stark ins
zentrum gerückt ist manchmal auch gar
nicht wirklich reflektiert wird bisschen
genauer beschreiben wie ich sie mir
denke wie wir sie verstehen sollten
virtuelle realität mit virtuelle
realität sollte mich bloße simulation
verstehen also spielereien oder die
analogie ins virtuelle realitäten zu der
uns sitzt ikone krise immer mehr hinter
die sind genauso verbindlich genau so
real wie es nicht virtuelle realität
sind
nachdem wir uns aber immer natürlich
wieder zurück sehen also wir sehen uns
alle zurück im seminarraum zu
unterrichten oder unterrichtet zu werden
also physisch präsent zu sein ich glaube
wir brauchen gar nicht so viel uns
zurücklehnen sondern wir sollten nach
vorne blicken welche dinge die krise uns
nun eröffnet hat ermöglicht hat wir
werden nämlich durch virtuelle
realitäten unabhängig von ordentlichen
begrenzt und deswegen ist darin auch
eine form von freiheit enthalten die wir
ja gerade jetzt durch die krise glauben
zu verlieren
also ich möchte einen anderen blick
darauf wie ich glaube wir gewinnen an
freiheit virtuelle realität wir
erschaffen dann virtuelle realitäten
wenn wir gezwungen sind etwas neues zu
erschaffen weil wir durch bestimmte
umstände gehindert werden wird für die
bewohner krise und diese neue realität
erzeugen das ist neben gerade die
virtualität und virtuelle realität kann
auf ganz verschiedene weise bestehen
also die simulation die hat insofern
kein realen gehalt als immer nur
struktur analog die realität die
physische realität etwa modell
virtuell modellieren nicht sondern sie
sind eigenständig und jetzt habe ich
hier mal so ein schaubild zur übersicht
als ein vorschlag wir haben also
realitäten die physikalisch seien
physisch mental gedanken die haben eine
eigene realität und eben auch virtuell
wie zum beispiel ein online seminar was
ganz neue möglichkeiten durch die
digitalisierung geöffnet realität
hingegen sehe ich in solchen funktionen
wie simulationen oder illusion ettal
tendenziell also wir sollten nicht in
meinen augen die virtuelle realität der
bloße simulation gleichsetzen dann damit
unterschätzen wir unsere möglichkeiten
auf krisen wie die krone krise zu
reagieren
so jetzt kann man sich genauer fragen
wir sehen diese virtuelle realitäten aus
für den ich gesprochen habe
ganz wichtig ist scheint mir zu sein
dass in der korona krise auch die
digitalisierung besonders an fahrt
aufgenommen hat wie alle kommunizieren
person und ich finde zumindest aus
meiner erfahrung dass das letzte
semester bei mir der philosophie sehr
gut funktioniert hat mit zu wir haben
andere möglichkeiten der digitalen
medien die wir einbinden können apps
blogs youtube kanäle und so weiter das
ist alles dinge die durch die krise
erstmals wirklich ernst genommen werden
die nicht mehr nur als spielerei abgetan
werden sind die wirklich systematisch
integriert und fruchtbar gemacht und die
digitalisierung scheint mir so das
vehikel zu sein mit dem wir durch
virtuelle realität auf dicke oder krise
eine antwort formulieren können und uns
damit nicht geschlagen geben müssen
oberwasser bis jetzt und jetzt gibt es
eine zentrale unterscheidung die ich
auch noch einführen möchte nämlich die
unterscheidung zwischen digitalisierung
und digitalität diese virtuelle realität
in diesen ganzen verschiedenen
ausformungen der kommunikation die
korrespondenz die betrifft die
digitalität das ist eine lebensform eine
neue kulturelle realität durch die wir
jetzt eben immer mehr auf die wir immer
mehr gestoßen werden durch die krise was
ist jetzt der unterschied zwischen
digitalität und digitalisierung
digitalisierung betrifft
phänomene der umwandlung von analoge und
digitale information
die digitalität hinkriegen jetzt
repariert oder reflektiert auf die
lebensweltliche bedeutung der
digitalisierung also wie wir unseren
alltag aber nicht nur unseren alltag
unser denken unser unterrichten unsere
praxis als solche wie die transformiert
wird und das ist wie mir scheint die
virtuelle realität
jetzt kann man das ganz einfach zeigen
wir können die da wir können daten
unabhängig von raum und zeit
konservieren wir können sich über text
will vernetzen
wir können virtuelle handlungen
vollziehen indem wir nur einmal mit der
maus klicken im internet
wir können unsere identität verschleiern
andererseits hinterlassen wir auch nicht
mehr lösbar im internet dh unsere
realität begriff wird transformiert aber
auch unser raum und zeit begriff wird
strapaziert wenn wir virtuelle realität
als realität ernst nehmen damit ist
jetzt noch ein bisschen genauer
beschreiben
egl hat gesagt philosophie bedeutet das
was ist zu begreifen und ihre zeit in
gedanken zu fassen
wenn das wirklich die aufgabe der
philosophie ist dann müssen wir für
diese traum der digitalität auf denen
wir durch die krise gekommen sind
neue begriffe prägen mir scheint sich
hier verschiedene begriffe anzubieten zb
der begriff der inter objektivität und
im gegensatz zu inter subjektivität was
bedeutet dass in dem raum der
digitalität treten gegenstände
smartphones smartphones und smart
objects weiter sofort immer mehr in
verbindung das heißt auch gegenstände
korrespondiere und nicht nur subjekt die
beziehung zu gegenständen oder auch
gegenstimmen untereinander wird immer
dichter die vernetzung schreitet fort
was ja auch das prinzip des internets
ist auch auf zeit spielen andere rolle
weil wir auf alle daten zugreifen können
und ganz lang vergangen ist durch ein
klick ins bewusstsein leben können und
hier der zeitliche index gar nicht mehr
so relevant ist ich würde dieses
phänomen der ubiquitären präsentismus
nennen also überall und zu jeder zeit
können wir präsenz herrscht
das heißt unser zeitbegriff wird auch im
rahmen der virtuellen realität der
digitalität transformiert jetzt habe ich
hier sehr positive dinge hervorgehoben
ich möchte aber auch die negativen den
nicht verschweigen
es gibt nämlich auch virtuelle probleme
die natürlich einher gehen mit dieser
veränderten raum und zeit logik
entstehen zb problematik das vergangene
ereignisse nicht wirklich vergehen ich
hatte gesagt die sekretäre präsentismus
erlaubt das alles wieder jetzt
bewusstsein zu heben und die zeitlichen
index völlig herauszunehmen
das internet vergisst nichts es ist eine
art gewaltiges kulturelles gedächtnis
dass alle informationen nur
nebeneinander will nicht kausal wirklich
jetzt seine europa bringt wir können
alles mit einem klick in beziehung
setzen
das ist das was anderes als wir mit der
physischen realität umgehen
und deswegen hat auch die charta der
digitalen grundrechte der europäischen
union ein recht auf vergessen werden
gefordert dass lautet jeder mensch hat
das recht auf digitalen neu anfangen das
finde ich sehr unterstützenswert
das heißt wir müssen auch schauen wie
jetzt durch die krise neue form von
realitäten ethisch zu verwerten sind wir
sollten also nicht nur optimistisch sein
so immer kritisch auch die sind
phänomene begleiten
für den sprecher der autor dieses sehr
lesenswerten buches die 50 wichtigsten
themen der digitalisierung schreibt
diese wird uns mit der wohl größten
zivilisatorischen herausforderung
konfrontiert die es je zu bewältigen und
den kann ich eigentlich nur zuzustimmen
diese digitale herausforderung die tritt
gerade diesem moment auf wo die krone
krise unsere gesamte zivilisation
bedroht und wir sollten meinen augen das
beste daraus machen und das heißt
virtuelle realität also neues erschaffen
im sinne einer evolution reagieren auf
probleme auf und freiheiten und neue
räume öffnen und dieses sinnvoll aber
auch kritisch ist kritisch zu fühlen
das sind eben zu rehabilitieren vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit